I mean I was jogging I hate jogging
jogging is the worst Chris I mean I know
it keeps you healthy but God what costs
actually the dress that Julia Roberts
wore as a prostitute in Pretty Woman I
know I look really good at it do you
like a sweat suit or something I need to
send out a signal that nothing is gonna
happen oh this is insane
it's so obvious you're dying to be
together and now you're going on a road
trip I mean you guys could literally get
a room yeah and I could literally get a
fired alright I will help you anti
seduce him just tell me what else you
need I need to think of unsexy boring
conversation topics we can talk about in
the car I have a few ideas we could
discuss the New Yorker article the
history of the latter okay we could talk
about different dorms Johns Hopkins
University and I could read for my
Sonicare booklet oh I have a good idea
what why don't you ask him about his
penis and Perkins Chris hey I heard you
were back I didn't do this because of
you well it looks great yeah you look
great am i right it's so good running
into you yeah we should get together
soon I'd love to catch up me too
ketchup and mustard ketchup and mustard
oh Jesus
oh I relish your whip well I saw say
your face
what no damn it what are you betting on
it better not be Terrence Howard's tank
top and Hustle & Flow it is not good cuz
I am bidding on it and I am ready to
spend an amount that my accountant calls
dangerous and irresponsible JJ's diner
put an old waffle iron up for auction
it's the perfect breakfast a gift for
Leslie breakfast day Leslie has
anniversaries for everything
zoo day first time we went to the zoo
together double date day was the first
time we went on a double date Daniel
day-lewis day Talk Like a Pirate Day
talk like a Pittsburgh pirate day which
why and how this calendar was last
year's calendar day presents celebrating
the first time she ever bought me a
calendar there is a crazy flu going
around
lots of miserable dehydrated people with
-
and diarrhea and one of those dehydrated
high fever miserable people is April who
hates me
I want another nurse well there are none
we're stretched pretty thin right now
then I want a janitor they can do what
you do right yep nurses and janitors are
totally interchangeable except no one
dresses up like a janitor when they want
to be [ __ ] I get the sense that maybe
you're angry at me for kissing Andy no
I'm not what are you talking about
that's crazy and that you think it might
be fun to take it out on me please don't
do that do I can't do anything I'm sick
my blankets are on the floor I thought
you might like a fresh set of pillows
are you trying to smother me okay never
mind
stay back [ __ ] I know what she's trying
to do she's trying to get me to break
and you know what I'm not gonna do it
I'm gonna be professional and I'm gonna
put on a happy face and then I'm gonna
go into a supply closet and snap a bunch
of tongue depressors what 3 2 1 and my
shifts over what is your problem oh I
thought you weren't gonna lose it while
I was on duty I didn't now it's just me
I get that you're mad that I kissed Andy
okay but it was a moment of confusion
and it was a mistake and I'm very sorry
you want to hate me forever okay fine
you know what I don't care but you
shouldn't take it out on Andy because he
really likes you you did nothing wrong
just for the record I'm starting to hate
you too that's the most I've ever liked
Dan yeah just have mr. Trager call me
when it gets back in actually you know
what don't tell him that I called just
when he gets there can you text me and
tell me he's back
you know what let's just pretend this
didn't happen okay this is dirty burgers
calling Bay I actually tell you a secret
but if you tell anyone I will kill you
slowly with a giant syringe
good morning April what's your secret
I'm thinking about applying to
veterinary school in Bloomington oh my
god April that's great
whoa where'd you get that the Internet
so I really need a letter of
recommendation and since you work in a
hospital as a janitor nurse I was
wondering if maybe you would write one
for me really generally between us
April always has the upper hand and that
hand is usually giving me the finger or
pouring honey in my purse but now I have
the upper hand and I'm going to use it
to crush her into being nice to me I
would be happy to write you that letter
I actually know the guy who runs the
veterinary program over there because
you hooked up with him I'll hook up with
everyone I know oh yes we did hook up
but before I write you that letter you
have to spend the next week with me and
do everything I say so I have to be your
slave or something no you have to be my
friend no that is so much worse don't do
that you know I think any of the four
previous locations have worked but
there's something about this place it's
a really good energy here you know lots
of natural light it's tiny and awful and
loud and its own 14b industrial waste
cleanup site we should technically be
wearing hazmat suits right now this
seems like the kind of place a ska band
would go to shoot heroin I gotta say
this report is quite impressive miss
Knope
oh well thank you very much mr. city
manager and I have to say that the way
that you're rocking those slacks is
quite impressive as well well thank you
mm-hmm can we hurry this up please
what there's nothing wrong with
acknowledging the fantastic work of one
of your employees especially if she's
adorable
I am back at the parks department and
Ben is city manager but we're married so
it's kosher and awesome we live together
and work together and we are so in sync
that we finish each other we rehearse
that at home naked in bed please stamp
the form
I just want to admire it one more time
again fantastic work in fact such good
work I think I'm in
with you oh my god that's great news cuz
I'm in love with you too what stamps the
form okay let's not let run feel left
out we love you to run stamp the dam for
a group hug
little GH come on wow I think our love
made him angry I think he broke my wrist
I'm not kidding really
this looks like fun I want to try hmm
there's rules for this sweet pea is
Donna Stern next I'll save my time to an
I feel like they'll be good okay well
I'm not gonna talk for long cuz I have
to pee again it's not to pee every six
minutes coz of a beach ball in my
stomach that's punching on my bladder
I know and I'm never not hungry Oh what
have some change I can't have cheese
Larry and I can't have wine either I
can't have anything good you know what I
can have is liquefied flaxseed but I
don't want that you know what I want
pork rinds
I want jelly beans and I want a huge
trash bag filled with mashed potatoes I
want to be pac-man and instead of dots I
want him to be cinnamon buns I want to
be a giant head and a mouth and I just
want to eat rows and rows of junk food
pellets and where's my trash bag of
potatoes we just put a hundred of these
in their body new trio by sweetums if
you can't beat up sweet oh I love that
song oh are you gonna check my email
we're gonna sell these in the park Manor
healthy holy God no they're not they're
terrible for you picture Lance Armstrong
on there look at the ingredients
high-fructose corn syrup corn syrup only
eight grams of fat per serving a bar is
four servings well people seem to enjoy
them look how happy everybody is
[Applause]
yeah that's a sugar rush yeah yeah that
makes sense you're gonna crash soon and
it's not gonna be pretty
yeah I'm gonna crashed into cuz I've
eaten like 40 of these generally I like
to stay out of other people's business
but Pawnee is the fourth most obese city
in America the kids here are beefy
they're just husky Big Bone plus-sized
chunk monsters I call maka cm Ann
Perkins hey Chris got a renault meeting
with Ron great idea I'll run to my next
meeting
sorry the door was open I wish this
office had only walls Chris broke up
with his girlfriend a week ago and I
have decided to ask him to be the father
of my baby
except I cannot work up the nerve to do
it turns out they don't make greeting
cards for asking your ex-boyfriend if
you will artificially inseminate you
actually Ron I could use your advice on
how to be blunt and honest I want my
friend to do something for me and I
don't know how to ask him what do you
want him to do plant ficuses in my front
yard grossest metaphor ever I've seen
your house you'd have more success if he
planted ficuses in your backyard no I
don't think so
you